- [Alex] Good afternoon, everyone.
So how is it going? How is re:Invent?
All good?
So welcome to this code talk.
So this is code talk.
So I assume that you love see code
more than like seeing PowerPoint.
So this is the goal of this session
and also I assume that most of you
have .NET developer background
and you're dealing with
some legacy .NET framework applications
that you need to modernize.
So welcome everyone. I'm Alex.
- [Prasad] I'm Prasad.
- [Alex] And I'm based
in Stockholm, Sweden.
- [Prasad] I'm based in London, UK.
- [Alex] And here in this
session we will show you
how you can modernize
your legacy .NET framework applications
using agentic AI tools like
AWS Transform and Kiro.
And we'll do a lot of live
coding because of this code talk.
So before we get started,
I know just raise of hands,
like, how many still
managing some kind of like
.NET framework applications,
like legacy stuff?
- [Prasad] Okay, almost
everyone seems like in the room.
- [Alex] Perfect.
So you're in the right session.
Good.
Okay, let's get started.
- [Prasad] Yeah, so when we talk about
legacy .NET applications,
there are three components
to it which are legacy
which we need to modernize.
The first is the framework.
You know, the language that is
written is in .NET framework.
So .NET framework as you know,
can run only on Windows, it's proprietary.
So we'd like to modernize it
to the latest version of .NET,
.NET 8 or .NET 10.
like, both are the long term
support versions that we have.
So that's the first part of modernization
that we'll be doing,
the code modernization.
The second is the
architecture modernization,
which means that your application
might be a monolith, right?
And where you're modernizing
you would like to
use the best practices
architectural patterns.
So you'll be using microservices,
even driven architectures.
So that's the architecture modernization.
And finally it is
infrastructure modernization.
So as you know, your .NET
framework applications
can run only on Windows.
So you'd like to run them on Linux
and most probably if
it's ASP.NET application
it will be running on iOS.
So instead of that you
would like to run it
on serverless containers or EC2 Linux.
So we are going to look into that.
So in this particular session,
why modernize all these three aspects
of the legacy application?
And to do that, what we have done
is that we have taken a
open source application
called Contoso University.
It's a ASP.NET application.
It has standard features,
it's a university management
application which has features
like student enrollment,
course management,
instructor assignment, right?
And as you can see
it is built quite heavily
using Windows components.
For example, for your
queues, it is using MSMQ.
For your database, it is using SQL server
and if you look at the presentation layer,
it is using Razor Views
with MVC controller
and then it has your service layer,
not a typical service layer,
but it has a notification service
which sends out
notifications via your MSMQ.
And then in the data layer
it has entity framework
which it uses to connect
to your SQL server,
communicate to SQL server.
So that's the architecture
which you're going to modernize.
But let's look at the code,
how the current code
base looks like, Alex?
- [Alex] Okay, let me move to my keyboard.
So as you saw, like,
this is quite typical
.NET framework application
which contains like
quite typical components,
which probably you see
in your applications
I know from last 20 years.
But let me switch to the code.
So I have this application
in my GitHub repository.
So as you can see it's .NET
framework 4.8 application.
Yeah, it's like this huge project file.
So all the configuration is in web config.
And then what we have,
so we have you know,
bunch of controllers,
we have database with like
some initializer with database
context, we have some views.
As I said, this is a university
management application.
So we have views to manage
courses, departments,
instructors, students.
So this is not like a small
hello world application,
but it's not like enterprise application.
But again this is very good application
for demo purposes we should picked.
So what are we going to
do with this application?
- [Prasad] Yep, so let's switch
to the presentation again
and let's see what we
are going to do, right?
So we have seen the code base
of the legacy application
architecture of the legacy application.
Let's talk about the tooling
that we'll be using to
modernize this, right?
The first we'll be using
AWS transform for .NET
through which we will be porting
your .NET framework application
to latest version of .NET,
in this session we'll be doing it .NET 8
and then we will be using Kiro.
So what we'll do is that
we'll take the ported code
from AWS Transform for .NET
and then we will use Kiro
to fix any compiled errors,
build it locally and then
we'll modernize the code base.
We'll look into each of the steps
at what we are going to
do when I say modernize.
So the step number one
is automatically put,
that will be using AWS
transform your code base
to the latest version of .NET.
Step number two would be fixing
any compiled errors and
building them locally.
And that's when we'll start refactoring.
We'll replace your SQL
server with PostgreSQL.
Then we are going to replace
MSMQ with Amazon SQS.
So what we are trying to do
is that we are going to remove
all the Windows components,
legacy components
and make it a more cloud
native application.
Then we're going to extract
a microservice from this monolith.
Then we are going to refactor the UI.
So currently as you
have seen the refactor,
the UI is based on your
MVC controller Razor Views.
We are going to move it to React app.
And then finally we are
going to deploy it on AWS
by creating a CDK project.
So like in next 45 minutes or so,
we are going to go
through all of these steps
and why modernize it?
With that, let's start with the step one,
updating a .NET framework
application to .NET 8.
- [Alex] Okay, let's switch to the code.
So as Prasad said,
the first service we're
going to use is AWS Transform
and yesterday we completely changed
the UI of AWS Transform,
like edit the new features.
So this is the new UI of AWS Transform.
So I already have a workspace created
and if I go to this workspace,
I already have a connector configured
to my GitHub repository.
So AWS Transform can access the code
like in my GitHub repository.
So this is the sample
Contoso University project.
So this is the connector, it is active,
and then yeah, it's
connector for GitHub GitLab.
So what I'm going to do, I'm
going to create a new job.
I'm just saying create job.
- [Prasad] How many of you
here have used AWS Transform?
Okay, a few of them.
Have you heard about this service?
It went GA earlier this year.
Okay, few of them. Okay, cool.
- [Alex] Okay, so now it ask me what kind
of transformation job do I want to do?
Because AWS Transform
can do multiple things.
So it can transform your
mainframe applications,
VMware based applications,
but in this case we're going
to do .NET modernization.
So now it's called Windows modernization
because yesterday we
launched a new feature.
So it can not only modernize
your .NET framework applications,
it can also modernize
your SQL server database.
So I'm saying okay, I want
to do Windows modernization
and in this case I'm going
to .NET modernization.
Okay, so this is,
the job is going to create for me.
- [Prasad] So as you can see,
it's a more agentic AI experience.
You would be having, you know,
a modern UI to go through.
- [Alex] Yeah and this is like,
not fully automated experience.
So it involves me as a
developer in the loop.
So as you see, it's saying
okay, I'm awaiting user input.
And what it wants me to
do is to say okay, like,
where do I get the source
code to be transformed from?
And we have like, two type
of connectors supported.
One is through code connections.
So okay, if your source code is
in GitHub, GitLab, Azure DevOps,
when you can do it
through code connections
or if your source code
is in your S3 bucket.
So maybe you are not storing
it in GitHub or whatever.
So okay, you can connect
to your S3 bucket.
In my case it's in GitHub.
So okay, I'm just saying
my code is in the,
use code connections to
connect to my repository
and now it will start discovery.
So it'll connect to my
source code repository
and try to see what kind
of .NET framework projects
or older versions of .NET core projects
do I have in my repository.
And again it's saying awaiting user input.
So it discovered that in my GitHub report
I have two projects with Gadgets Online
and with Contoso University.
So the beauty of AWS
transform is that it can do,
it can transform multiple
projects at the same time.
So I don't need to go
like, project by project,
I can select multiple projects
and transform them like in parallel.
But in this case I want to do
transformation of only one project.
So I'm selecting, okay,
this is Contoso University
and then I'm saying,
okay, start assessment.
So on the assessment phase
it will look at my project
to understand, okay, what kind of .NET,
what versions of .NET it's using,
what kind of NuGet packages it's using
other like any dependencies
to third party NuGet packages
or dependencies to other repositories.
So it can automatically
discover what, okay,
I have like, two projects
in my GitHub repository
and actually this project
is using NuGet package,
which is produced by another project.
So it'll automatically map,
like these dependencies.
And then yeah, so I
will select the project,
I will say like, okay,
submit the job and then
I will run the job.
So for this project,
the job took like, maybe
half an hour to run.
So I will go back to my workspace
and show the results of a previous run
because we don't have time to
do like, live run of this job.
So I have it here again,
I mean I choose the connector
type, discover the repository
and did the transformation.
And here are transformation results.
So because it does, it
can do transformation
of multiple projects at the same time,
the outcome of transformation
is a new branch in each and every project.
So in my case it created the this branch,
which I named 1-transform
because it's the first step
of our seven step process.
So it created this new branch,
it transformed like, 3000 lines of code,
one repository, one project.
And when I can go deeper
and see like, all the
transformation details,
but okay, this is our starting point.
We did the transformation
using AWS Transform
and the transformed code is
in this transform branch.
Okay?
- Yep.
- [Alex] What's next?
- [Prasad] So what Alex showed here
is AWS Transform for .NET
and for those who are not
aware of this service,
Agentic AI experience
for modernizing your .NET applications,
and there are other features also
like your VMware applications,
mainframe applications,
but specific for .NET if we talk about
what Alex has shown is
a large scale porting.
And what we mean by large scale porting
is that you can select
more than one applications
to be modernized in one go.
But we also have a IDE extension,
a visual studio extension
for AWS Transform for .NET.
It's for developers who wants
to be in their, you know,
developer friendly experience environment.
They can use the visual studio extension
and have the same experience.
So irrespective of which pathway you go,
whether you go via web
console that Alex has shown,
or via ID experience,
it does three things.
First it analyzes your code base,
which is the assessment part,
then it does the transformation
replacing your code base in a way
that it is compatible
with the latest version
and then finally it validates, right?
So the outcome, the goal here
is to come up with a code base
that is, you know, Linux ready application
with compatible, right?
So now that's what we have done now.
Now we will take this ported code
and we'll use Kiro to fix
any compiled time errors
and build it locally, right?
So let's have a look at the step two now.
- [Alex] Yes, let's switch to the code.
So I'm switching now to Kiro.
So this is the branch which
was created by AWS Transform.
So if I go to this branch,
so this is my one transform branch
and you see what it was
committed by AWS Transform,
55 files were changed.
There is a lot of code changed
and if I go to the source code,
you see that now it's a .NET 8 project.
So how do I see it if I go to the project?
Yeah, you see the project file
is much smaller because it's .NET 8.
Yeah, the target framework is .NET 8.
My configuration is now moved
to application settings.
All the static files
were moved to WW route.
So okay, this is, I have like programs CS,
have like startups CS,
so it was transformed,
did all the undifferentiated heavy lifting
of porting my .NET framework
application to .NET 8,
but there are like still few things left.
So for example, if I go to this
project and say .NET build,
actually there are a few build errors.
So in many cases AWS Transform
the output will be good
like, compilable project.
In some cases, for example in this one,
there are still some things are missing.
So here it's a mismatch, some
versions of NuGet packages.
And again, as a developer probably
I would be able to fix
it like in a few minutes,
like in a half an hour.
But let's see if we can fix
it automatically using Kiro.
So I would just clear that.
And then this is the chat with Kiro.
So I'm saying okay,
I got built errors,
please fix it.
I'm trying to be polite
to Kiro so it works.
Yeah, so first thing it's going to do,
it's going to build a project itself
so it can hook to the console output
and see what our built
errors actually are.
Okay, so it got the output and says,
oh, I see the issue there is
a package version conflict.
So it reads my project file,
updated some version
so I can see all the
changes that were done.
And it says okay, I
want to build it again.
Okay, so it build it, okay,
there are two more errors it looks like.
Some still it's using like, MVC namespace,
which doesn't exist in the .NET 8.
Okay, so it did few more changes,
tries to build it again.
So again, these are the steps
which I will do myself as a developer.
So this will be like my, you
know, debugging experience,
but I'm offloading this
debugging experience to Kiro
and then just following, okay,
does it make sense from
my developer perspective?
And then it found like there is also issue
in this error Razor View that,
okay, it's using the system web we see,
which is not available ISP .NET core.
Okay, so it's fixed it.
Okay, one more error it says,
but okay, there is a
post build copy task we should fix.
- [Prasad] It keeps packing
itself back, gate progress.
- [Alex] Yeah, and okay .NET built.
Okay, no more errors but it
looks like there was a warning.
And again Kiro says, okay,
like there is a warning.
Okay, let me fix this warning as well.
So it's yeah, trying to
make it as good as possible
and we run it okay, it's fixed.
Build succeeded, zero
warning, zero errors.
So how long it took for me and Kiro
to fix this build issues
around one minute,
couple of minutes, probably?
- Couple of minutes.
Yeah, so.
- Okay,
so now our project is compatible locally
and it's .NEt 8 project already.
I'm running it Mac,
it's not .NET framework,
it's .NET 8 project.
Okay, what's next?
- [Prasad] Cool, now it
is like building locally.
So let's see what next we can do.
But how did we do that?
We did using Kiro and AI
IDE that went into GA last,
a couple of weeks back actually.
It was on preview for some time.
And what's beautiful about this AI IDE
is that you provide the intent that
what you want to achieve
in natural language,
not the actual code,
you don't write the actual code,
Kiro writes the actual
code on your behalf, right?
And there are two ways
to provide your intent.
First is what has Alex has shown, right?
Which is mainly known as by
coding, like prompt engineering,
you provide the prompt
and Kiro does the changes on your behalf
and it's pretty good for
tasks like as we have shown,
fixing errors, troubleshooting,
or you know, in case if you
want to build rapid prototypes,
like, I use it all the time for
creating POCs for customers.
But in case if you are doing more like,
you know, complex tasks
and building, you know,
production grade applications,
then probably you might want
to use spec driven development.
Live coding might not be
the best way to go forward
and thus Kiro supports spec development.
And we'll dive deep into it in
a moment when we'll be doing
the more complex aspects
of the modernization that we are showing.
But for now, let's look into
where we are in our journey.
So we complete the first two steps,
the third step is now replacing
SQL Server with Postgres
and Alex, I believe we
are going to continue
by coding for that?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
And here if you see in that,
if you look at the architecture diagram,
what is happening first and second is done
and we are gonna focus
here on the SQL server.
We'll replace this with Postgres SQL.
Go for it, Alex.
- [Alex] Yeah, let's switch to the code.
So again, I'm running it on Mac
and with Pro there is dependence
on SQL Server local DB,
so I still cannot run it
but I have a local instance
of PostgreSQL running on my machine.
So I want to switch from
SQL server to PostgreSQL.
So first let me switch
to my PostgreSQL.
So you see, let me create a new database.
So it's brand new empty database.
Create database Contoso 99, I dunno.
I dunno why 99, but okay,
so I just created this new database
and then let me switch to Kiro
and then I'm just writing, okay?
Like again in Vibe code,
in mode I'm saying okay,
I want to switch to PostgreSQL.
I have local instance
running database name
Cantoso 99.
User name, this is my name,
and it's my local database.
So I have empty password, okay?
So this is my intention,
what I want to do with this
application and Kiro says okay,
I will help you to switch
from SQL Server to PostgreSQL,
let me check your current
setup, make necessary changes.
So it's checking the,
my project file is checking
my application settings
database context startup file
and it's now starting making the changes
and I'm doing everything live.
Nothing is recorded.
- [Prasad] Let's see how it does
and what model are we using, Alex, here?
- So currently we're
using Claude Sonnet 4.5.
So this is the latest
version of Claude Sonnet.
- [Prasad] Yeah.
- [Alex] Okay, so it's
ask me to do .NET restore.
- [Prasad] Can you point
in the screen where
now the model can be changed?
Just for everyone in case
they have not used Kiro.
- [Alex] Yeah, so we are,
yeah, we can switch
between different models.
- [Prasad] How many of
you here has used Kiro
or you know, like have
hands-on experience with Kiro?
Very few, okay?
- [Alex] And has anyone used Kiro
to modernize old applications
or only for prototyping?
Okay.
- [Prasad] I highly recommend too,
like, you know, it's a free,
it's not a free but you know,
once you install it'll give
you a good amount of credits
and then every month you
get some credits free.
So try it out. It's a
fork of Visual Studio.
So you will still be in
a very developer friendly
experience that you might be having,
sorry VS Code, it's a fork of VS Code.
So you'll be still be
in a very friendly
development environment.
- [Audience Member] So you'll install it
and you plug it into the Studio?
- [Prasad] No, it's a separate ID.
You can simply install the
ID and that's pretty much,
so you don't need to
install VS Code for it.
You can simply go to
Kiro and install Kiro.
- [Alex] Okay, so it did
the first batch of changes.
So it says okay, it's
updated application settings,
it's updated the project file,
updated the database context.
Okay, so let's try to run it.
- [Prasad] While you're
running, you had a question.
- [Audience Member] Are you planning
for a Visual Studio plugin for it as well?
- [Prasad] So for Visual Studio
we have plugin for AWS Transform,
for Kiro, I'm not sure yet.
- [Alex] Okay, so I try to run it
and there is an error.
So there is a,
okay, so it says that unhandled
exception entity framework,
datetime2 is not supported.
So okay, probably I'm using this datetime2
in my SQL server code,
but datetime2 is not
available in PostgreSQL.
So again as developer I can fix it myself
but what I'm going to do,
I'm just going to
copy this stack trays and ask Kiro.
I have runtime exception,
and I'm just pasting the...
- [Prasad] That's a new
way of development, right?
So as a developer we keep guiding,
Let's say Kiro is a junior developer
and they keep doing it for us.
So it's a kind of a programming
pairing or you know,
whichever way you would like to associate,
a friendly developer is
always there for you.
- [Alex] Yeah, so it's trying to find
like, the references of
datetime2 in different projects,
updating the notification,
accepted the edit to it
and then now it's saying, okay,
let me check the other models.
So again, this is something
which I as developer would do.
Okay, like if I fix a
error I will try to see,
okay, if similar errors
exists in our code files.
Okay, so I was able to build it.
Let me run it again.
It looks like there is
datetime2 exist somewhere else.
Yeah, now it's in person table.
But again, let me just
copy this stack trace
and say got
runtime error
and I'm pasting it in the same session.
So Kiro knows like, the context,
okay, this is my conversation
about PostgreSQL migration.
- Yeah.
- And this says okay,
I found these issues in person model
and students model, instructor model.
So it's trying to fix
it in all other classes.
- [Prasad] While it is fixing, yes?
You have a question please?
- [Audience Member] What
makes Kiro different
than using like Cursor or like,
Copilot with the same model?
- [Prasad] So it's like it
has much deeper integration
with your AWS services
and we'll see show you
how you can deploy it
all using CDK project in AWS.
- [Alex] Okay, so let me build it
and let me run it again.
.NET run.
Okay, so now at least I don't
have like runtime errors
and it's running on local host 5,000.
So let's see,
so this is my application.
So again it's up, so it's
like .NET 8 application
already is running on my Mac
and if I go to students page,
okay, something is not working
so it looks like I get
another runtime error.
So let's see.
- [Prasad] So the page is loading
but it's not able to load the data, right?
- [Alex] Yeah.
So the connection string
was not initialized.
So okay again, let me just
copy it.
- [Prasad] Yes, while Alex is fixing it,
please go ahead ask the question.
- [Audience Member] Does
it support other models
than what is shown there?
- [Prasad] Yeah,
we'll show in a moment what
other models it supports.
- So currently as it can-
- We can see the differences.
- [Prasad] Try it out, experiment.
- [Alex] So you see,
there is like this Claude
Sonnet 4.54, Haiku, Opus,
and then yes, it's OpenCoder.
Okay, but now again,
now it's trying to fix
another random error
but the connection string was
not correctly initialized.
So let's see.
So it's trying to find,
okay, like whatever control,
I mean.
- Yeah, please go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Yeah
regarding the sort of the AI,
if you have like GitHub
Copilot or some other thing,
would they integrate with that
or is this a separate service?
- [Prasad] So it's a ID in itself, right?
So and it has the
inbuilt, what do you call?
AI capabilities.
I don't think that it
is going to integrate
with GitHub or Copilot.
No, I would try it out or not try it out.
- [Alex] Okay, so yeah,
we're still like in this
maybe it's not vibe coding mode,
it's like vibe debugging mode.
We're trying to fix this
issue with PostgreSQL.
So, but okay, let's see
and let's run it again
and I think it's still on the port 5,000.
Okay, so now the page is loaded.
So it looks like I don't
have like any runtime errors
but there is no data on this page
and I know that this project,
it has the database initializer,
which like, seeds the sample data.
So again I can ask Kiro.
Or not ask, I'm just making the statement
with same sample data is not seeded.
- [Prasad] So as a developer,
you still need to know
what needs to be done
and then you keep
instructing Kiro, but okay,
can you please do this on our behalf?
And they'll keep doing it hopefully
- [Alex] Again this is
like my fair programmer,
I'm talking to Kiro and trying
to solve the issues together.
- [Prasad] Yes please?
- [Audience Member] And is
it same like Copilot, Kiro?
- [Prasad] It's a lot more
efficient, I would say.
- [Audience Member] It's the same, right?
- [Prasad] Yeah, similar capabilities
and as I mentioned it has
a much deeper integration
of the AWS Services when
it comes to deployment.
We look into this, how
we'll create a CDK project
and we'll deploy it on AWS.
- [Alex] Yeah, so like what we see that
it's the database
initializer was not called.
So now we call initializer,
okay let's build,
- [Prasad] Okay, yes please continue.
- [Audience Member] So I mean,
we do have results studio, right?
- [Prasad] VS Code or Visual Studio?
- [Audience Member] Which on is that?
- [Prasad] This is VS
Code for the Kiro ID.
- [Audience Member] My point was,
Visual Studio automatically
does the compiling, right?
- [Prasad] Yes.
- [Audience Member] So now we have to
initially install Kiro or what it was?
- [Prasad] You can continue using that
but in case if you would like to,
so Kiro is a great alternative.
- [Alex] Maybe let's leave
it for the discussion,
like maybe after this session
because we are really short of time,
like to show what we want to show.
So we are still progressing
with this upgrade from
SQL Server to PostgreSQL
and there is this maybe I
hope if this is the last error
that it's, yeah.
So there is an error when
it's trying to seed the data.
So yeah, let's see what it's all about.
And yeah, we got run time error
seeding the data.
Yeah, so again this is like
still issue with datetime
that you need to specify
if like UTCO local.
So this is the PostgreSQL
specific feature.
So let me, yeah it did some changes.
Let's build it
and let's run it.
.NET run.
Okay, update the page,
and okay, so here we have
a data so we just upgrade.
So now this application is
running locally on my macOS,
it's .NET 8 application
and instead of SQL Server
it's using PostgreSQL
and it took us, I dunno how many,
maybe 20 minutes in total
of like, vibe coding with Kiro.
- Yeah, and until now.
- Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
- So what's next?
- [Prasad] So let's see
where we are in our journey.
So we did modernize from
SQL server to PostgreSQL.
The next step is MSMQ to Amazon SQS.
And if you look at the collection diagram,
if you look at like where
the three is written.
So we replaced SQL server
with PostgreSQL there
and now we are going to focus on the MSMQ
and make it Amazon SQS.
And this I think we are going to do it
with spec driven development
and this is where the
actual differentiation
would come into picture,
the spec development.
- [Alex] Okay, let's switch to code.
- [Prasad] Yeah, let's switch to code.
- [Alex] So I will start the new session
and instead of like vibe coding,
I'm now going into spec code mode
and I already have my prompt,
I don't want to type it, but okay,
so I'm saying current application
is using MSMQ for notifications.
I want to switch to SQS implementation.
I want just base functionality,
like no extensive error handling,
no unit test, no like, local testing.
So I want to keep it like, at MVP level
and I already have SQSQ created
and this is the URL of the queue
and now I'm like in the
spec development mode.
- [Prasad] So what does it
do in spec development mode?
- [Alex] Yeah, so first it's going
to create the requirements document.
And it will create
requirements document based on my project.
Okay, what does it mean?
Upgrading MSMQ to SQS
and we will see like this
document in a second.
Okay, so it's created the requirements
and now it will ask me to review it.
So you see there is a
new folder created .Kiro
and under .Kiro there is a specs folder
and it created this SQS
notification migration folder.
So again, the name makes perfect sense
based on my intent that
I want to migrate to SQS
and it's created this
requirement document.
So this specification
defines for migration
of this notification system from in memory
to in memory queue implementation
to SQS, some glossary.
But here are requirements, okay,
as an administrator I want notifications
to be sent to SQS instead
of in memory queue.
So notifications are persistent
across application restarts.
Second requirement,
as a developer I want to use SDK for .NET
so that application can
communicate with SQS.
Okay, also makes sense.
As a developer I want queue
URL to be configurable,
so like, different environment.
So I can have different queues
for when I'm in production environment,
for my test environment and so on.
And then also as a developer,
this is quite important.
So as developer I want
existing notifications
API to remain untouched.
So okay, I want to change
the underlying implementation
but not with interfaces.
So like all the services
we'd use notification,
service, I mean should be untouched.
Okay, so all these
requirements make sense to me.
I'm moving to design phase.
So what design phase is that?
Okay, these requirements
are quite generic.
So I would say that, okay,
these are requirements
for every project where you
migrate from MSMQ to SQS.
Now what Kiro will try to do,
it will try to apply these requirements
to my specific project.
Okay, what do I need to do in this project
in order to implement these requirements?
So this is the design phase
and it will take into account
the whole project structure,
my classes, my dependencies and so on.
So it's working on this design document.
So the design document is
created and yeah, let's see.
So it says, okay, look this
is the current architecture.
So again it went to my
source code to understand.
okay, what is the current architecture,
how it looks like?
I have notification service,
I have base controller, I
have notification controller.
Then okay, how the target
architecture should like,
okay, these are the changes
which has to be implemented.
And then it says, okay, like,
this is where it shows
also some code pieces.
Okay, this is how the
new notification server
should look like.
This is the interfaces,
some key design decisions,
this is the configuration.
So okay, I will add this into up settings,
the configuration of a queue,
the new dependencies, okay,
now the project must be dependent
on ED plus SDK, SQS and so on.
So again, when the notification
is saved in SQS it has to be serialized.
So this is the class
and this is how the
serialization will look like
and so on and so on.
So again, I can review
this design document.
As a developer, I can
make the changes to it,
but okay for me now it's good enough.
Move to implementation plan.
- [Prasad] So the whole process
is that once you provide
a intentional requirement,
then design and then
the implementation plan.
- [Alex] Yeah, so now
it's creating these tasks.
So tasks, these are single
units of implementation,
which Kiro is going to do with me
and now it's asking me, okay,
do I want to make it fast?
So some tasks keep as an optional ones
or do I want to make
all the tasks required?
Okay, we are in a short of time.
So okay, let's do this MVP
level of implementation.
So it's created the task list.
So let's look at them.
So these are the tasks, okay?
First task we need to add SDK dependency,
add when you get package
and then the add the
configuration to up settings.
When I need to update the
notification service to use SQS,
this is how is done.
And then okay, I need to
implement the send notification
with SQS instead of using MSMQ.
So I need to do the serialization,
send the message, get result.
I need to implement retrieve
notification and so on.
So these are like this list of tasks
which has to be implemented
in order to implement my requirements.
And then for each task I can
just say, okay, start task.
And then Kiro will do the implementation
of this specific first task, okay?
It'll add the dependency to SDK,
it'll add the NuGet package
and it'll update my configuration,
so that's my up settings.
So it's working on this task.
- [Prasad] It kind of
follows the full SDLC cycle.
First you're creating the requirements
and then the resign tasks
and then it starts implementing
the tasks on your behalf.
- [Alex] Yeah, so actually it follows,
like, my own mental model, okay?
As a developer probably
I will do the same steps.
I will figure out, okay,
what our requirements are
then I will figure out, okay,
how is requirements are
applicable to my specific project?
And okay, like in order to implement it,
okay, what do I need to do?
Like, exactly what tasks?
So Kiro is working
and this is the beauty of a live demo.
So you don't know what to expect,
but, okay.
You got the idea.
So let me quickly switch to a new branch.
So I will just undo all the changes,
discard everything.
And then I already
have a branch with implemented feature.
So just let me quickly switch to it.
So I have this branch
for SQS, so get, switch.
Yes.
So this is the,
this is the feature.
So these are requirements
and then yeah, I already
implemented this feature here.
Okay, so let's fast forward.
What's next?
- [Prasad] Yeah, so let's
go to the presentation mode.
So what we have seen is
the spec driven development
and that's the main
differentiating factor, right?
So vibe coding is good and that
is available like, you know,
and multiple other tools also, but,
and that is good for, you know,
rapid prototyping and
quick fixing the issues.
But in case if you are, you know,
you need a more in depth
thinking, you need a more,
you know, production
level projects to be built
and that's where the
spec driven development
comes into a picture that we have seen.
But when talk about the journey,
like, where we are right now currently
that we did the MSMQ to Amazon SQS,
the next part that we're going to do
is actually extract our microservice to,
from this small length,
like, that's what we're
going to work on next.
So we are going to extract
this notification service
into its own service again
using the spec driven
development, right Alex?
- [Alex] Yes, let's switch to demo.
So again, for the sake
of time I will show like,
what kind of specification was generated
and how the project was changed.
- [Prasad] Yep.
- [Alex] So I will
switch to another branch.
So it's with notification service.
So if I go to Kiro folder
now I have another
specification which was created
with notification service extraction.
And again, if I go to requirements
it says okay, these are requirements
for extraction of notification service
from this monolith application
into separate .NET 8 web microservice.
So I can deploy it independently,
I can scale it independently.
So this is the beauty of microservices.
- [Prasad] So this is the kind
of intent that you provided
with which it created this specification.
- [Alex] Yeah, so now
first requirement, okay,
as an architect I want
identification service
to be extracted into
separate web pay project
so it can be deployed
and scaled independently.
As a developer I wanted to
expose rest API endpoints
so I can send notifications
and the main applications can
send notifications using HTTP
and it goes like into more details, okay?
The endpoint should be exposed
at API/notifications and so on.
Okay, as a developer I
want notification API
to expose endpoints to
receive notifications, okay?
As a developer I want to use HTP client
to communicate with notifications API.
So I don't want to do
like, direct references,
I want to decouple it
and use the HTTP calls
in between main application
and identification service.
And yeah, as operator I want everything
to be configured in the URL.
So okay, there is a URL
of notification API,
which can be changed
based on the environment.
And the last one here,
like, proper dependency ejection,
again everything makes sense
from my developer standpoint.
Proper configuration files
and I want existing controllers
to continue working without changes.
So again, this call,
I mean switch between in process call
to the HTTP call should be done,
like, in the lower implementation level
so that the APIs are not changed.
And then yeah, it created
design based on this.
So like, design here
again it shows the flow,
what it gave us.
Application is called notification service
notification services
called notification API,
and notification API is using the SQSQ
and it goes like, into details, okay?
The base controller uses
this method and so on.
So again, design is like
how this specification is
implemented on my code base.
And then it ended up with
a list of tasks, okay?
Create this new web project,
set up all appropriate like
models dependency injection.
So I already, as you see,
implemented all these tasks.
So there is a new project
created side by side
with my Contoso University project.
It's called Notification API.
It has one controller,
it has like the service,
the model and then it's using the SDK SQS
to communicate with a queue
and also it removed the references
to SQS from my main project.
So, okay, where we are now?
- [Prasad] We are a bit short on time,
so we'll take the questions at the end,
we'll hang around even
after the session is over.
And so we'll take all the questions then.
We have around 14 minutes left
to showcase few extra
things that we have here.
So we did the step five,
which is extracting a
microservice from monolith.
So if you look from the
architecture perspective,
this is how it looks like now.
So we are incrementally
modernizing it, right?
Now one thing that we
would like to focus now
is refactoring the UI.
So when you talk about like you see,
.NET applications there,
UI is in this particular is
in Razor Views for example,
and we want to move it
to the modern UI frameworks like React.
So that's what we are going to do
right now in the next step,
refactoring the UI part.
- [Alex] Okay, let me switch.
So again, I will just
quickly switch to the branch
where I already refactored to UI.
- [Prasad] So how much
time does it take, Alex,
to do these refactoring like, you know?
- [Alex] So let me show first
the specification actually,
not even the specification,
let me show the tasks for
this React UI migration.
So you see now the list of tasks
is really, really huge
because what Kiro was
planning to do is, okay,
set up backend API infrastructure
because I'm switching from MVC controllers
to API controllers,
creating like all the response models,
data transfer objects,
create the students API controller,
create courses API controller,
create instructors API
controller, departments and so on.
Then yeah, initialized React application
using vibe and type script,
add the reference to material UI,
and then, yeah, configure API
and then it started
implementing the forms one by one.
So first it's APIs, okay?
Build students page,
create student list page,
create student form page,
create student create page.
And then same goes for
departments, same goes for courses.
So it's like very extensive list of tasks.
And again like,
these are the tasks which I as a developer
would need to do myself, okay?
Like if I get a task
convert from Razor Views
to React application, okay,
will be I know 50 forms which
I need to create manually
and these server tasks,
which I need to do,
form by form, like
implement with new forms.
And as I already implemented this task,
so back to your question, Prasad,
I think it took like maybe four
or five hours to like
implement all these tasks.
So and then again you can
think that okay, you know,
maybe it's like
significant amount of time,
I know working together with
Kiro, like, for five hours.
But then think about like,
if you do same migration
manually from like,
you know, Razor Views to React, okay,
how much it would take?
Maybe a couple of weeks for me
to implement always like 50
forms, APIs, controllers,
I mean everything like that.
Together with Kiro, it's
like less than a day
and this is this Cantoso
University UI application
implemented with, yeah, everything,
pages, components, I mean everything.
So again, structured in a very nice way.
So again, this is also
a way for me to learn,
like okay, what is the
best practices nowadays
to implement React
application, for example?
- [Prasad] Yeah, and that's where
the spec-driven development
really stands out
because it does create the specifications
then you can go and manually
edit those specifications
if needed and then you know,
ask it to implement a task,
revert a task if needed.
You can keep guiding it
and it'll keep doing it on your behalf.
So when it comes to like, vibe coding,
that's pretty straightforward
but spec-driven is where actually
you need to follow that
specific structure.
It'll help you actually implement
really complex aspects of it.
So now we did refactoring the UI
and the final part of it
would be actually
creating the CDK project.
But in case if you want
to look at the diagram,
so this is how it is, if you
look at the presentation layer,
it changes to React app and
instead of MVC controllers,
it is now API controllers, right?
So now let's do the last part of it,
which is deploying this whole
modernized applications.
A code base is running locally
and it is modernized locally,
but let's deploy it on AWS
by creating a CDK project.
- [Alex] Yeah, so again,
I already created a specification
and I already run
created with CDK project.
So I think like for CDK took
me maybe a couple of hours
to create a CDK project and deploy it
and then there were like
some small issues to fix.
But again, instead of
maybe a couple of days,
it took like a couple of hours.
So let me switch.
So again, I was using
spec-driven development.
So this is the specification
created at the CDK deployment.
So from requirements perspective,
I want to deploy with Cantoso
University application
using CDK, CDK using C#,
because CDK supports multiple languages
we want to use like C#,
and then it detected
for the key application
has three components,
React front end, main backend,
and also identification service API.
Also it must provision
required infrastructure compute database.
So instead of my local
PostgreSQL database,
it should provision
Aurora PostgreSQL database
and all supporting resources,
like no application load balance
or secrets manager to securely store
my database credentials and so on.
And then it's ended up creating the tasks,
create CDK project, create
the EC2 based deployment,
deployment scripts and so on.
So the output is this CDK project.
So it has like, multiple constructs,
constructs for my EC2
instances for backend services,
construct for the database,
for front end, for messaging.
And then also it created
a number of scripts
because when it deploys it to EC2,
it has to provision resources first,
then get the URL of a load balancer
and then update the React application
with this URL of a load
balancer for backend API
and then redeploy React application.
So Kiro automatically discovered
these dependencies, okay,
the deployment must be
like, in these steps,
like, in this order and
it created it for me.
So this is the application
which is deployed on CloudFront
and something failed recently,
like, my load balancer died.
But okay, this is the page with courses.
Yeah, okay, now it's failed load courses.
But again this is the React application
connected to the Amazon
Aurora PostgreSQL database
through the load balance.
So again, everything was
deployed by the CDK project,
which was created by me for me by Kiro.
- [Prasad] We can show
the architecture diagram.
So, let's switch to the slides
and let's look at the two slides.
So, we did the last step CDK project,
but when it comes to the
architecture diagram,
so you can see the front end,
the React app is deployed on S3 bucket
and it's front end by Amazon CloudFront.
The web API is deployed on
Amazon EC2 Linux instance
with ASP.NET core API controllers.
And it has, you know, in the same code
business entity framework
to talk to Amazon Aurora PostgreSQL.
So it's not just the
local PostgreSQL instance,
but they're deployed,
Amazon Aurora PostgreSQL.
And then if you can see there is another,
a service notification service.
It is deployed on separate EC2 instance
and that talks to your Amazon SQS.
So this is all the components
that were modernized
and deployed on AWS and Alex,
this is a simplified version
of that correction, right?
- [Alex] Yes, so this is
very simplified version
because there is
application load balancer,
it has this route-based...
- Path-based routing.
So like, web identification service,
there is also secrets managers
to connect to database and so on.
But here we just showing, okay,
these deployment components of,
so you can mentally map our
legacy analytic application
to a new architecture net with this.
- [Prasad] So that's where
the whole differentiation
of Kiro comes into picture,
the spec driven development
of structured way of doing it
and then you know, deploying it on AWS.
But if you look at, you know,
if I try and summarize
of what we have achieved
so far in this session
is that we started from
this legacy .NET application
with Razor Views and MVC controller
and Microsoft components
like MSMQ and SQL Server.
And what we ended up is this,
by doing the seven steps.
The first step,
putting your .NET framework
application to .NET,
then we actually fix
the errors and you know,
like, build it locally.
Then we replace SQL
Server with PostgreSQL,
and then we replaced MSMQ with Amazon SQS,
and then we wrote them all,
let them do microservices,
the notification service that is there
and then we refactored the UI to React,
and then finally we used
CDK to deploy it onto AWS
with all the components that is required
to make it a functioning application.
So that's pretty much
that we have for today
and we do have few resources
for you to get started.
You know, AWS Transform for .NET
for upgrading your .NET applications
and AWS and Kiro,
for you to actually do this whole,
not only just vibe coding
but also the spec driven development.
That's where the actual strength
of Kiro comes into picture,
the whole AI ID comes into picture.
I will pause for a moment for everyone
to take pictures who is, yeah.
And then we do have a few resources,
like a lot of agentic AI
courses on AWS Skill Builder.
So feel free to actually, you know,
go to it and a lot of
them are quite, you know,
are free available courses
on agentic AI on AWS
- [Alex] And thank you very much.
- Thank you very much.
- Hopefully you enjoyed it.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
And we are around here for any questions.
So yeah, we are here for the questions.